share Cheryl stop with the dishes you
always go hide in the kitchen whenever
we've got something to do you got to
take a look at this okay and stop with
the rinsing already you don't have to
look at me just listen I'm going to say
something I know there's a certain
relationship between a mother and
daughter and I'm not all quite in there
with it that view woman's perspective
but I'm bringing something here to you
know that daughter of ours has become a
fine young lady wonderful damn it that
doesn't mean she's just like you or me
we're gonna make the same choices to be
happy that's not what we want what you
want or is it all about what you want
what makes you happy I love that girl of
ours my daughter that she's become this
beautiful young woman with a mind of her
own reasonable and willing to stand up
for herself boy do I want that even if I
don't quite get it don't you don't you
want that for her take her life up into
your arms Cheryl embrace her like you've
done before if you can't do that make
room for her and you're hard and you
still say you love her then I've got to
reassess who you've become that you can
say you love somebody only to shut down
on them and shut them out do that for my
sake
she's being true to herself Cheryl and
I'm with her on this we have a
responsibility to that Cheryl do you
understand I'm with her
and we're going to have to start looking
out for myself to what love means to you
you follow